welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilshire host and our guest is
Musa Mubarak a professor of economics he
conducts field experiments exploring
ways to induce people in developing
countries to adopt technologies or
behaviors that are likely to be welfare
improving his ongoing research projects
are in Bangladesh Brazil Chile India
Kenya Nepal and Malawi professor Liu
barks work has been published in
numerous journals across disciplines
including econometrics science the
review of economic studies the American
Political Science Review and demography
today we'll talk with professor Mubarak
about breaking the hunger cycle in
Bangladesh welcome professor McGuire
thank you for having me
let's begin with the paper that was
published in econometrics dealing with
the migration and poverty in Bangladesh
give us an overview I'm sure I should
start with explaining why there is
seasonal poverty so it turns out that
about 300 million people in the world at
least even though they might not be
chronically poor they suffer from
seasonal hunger and this has to do with
the agricultural crop cycle so you know
farmers plant during a certain month
I'll use a Bangladesh calendar in August
they harvest in January and the period
in between if you're basically just
waiting for the crop to grow so there's
some work but not much the labor demand
fall so people who are landless who rely
on work on other people's farms right so
their wages fall and it also
unfortunately unfortunately happens to
be the time when the price of rice
spikes up this combination of high
prices and low wages means that caloric
intake goes down alright and this takes
the form of a seasonal famine so that's
true in Bangladesh in between the rice
growing season but it's also true in
other countries where I work like in
Malawi is called a hungry season he
needs to Ireland of Indonesia it has a
different name but it's the same
phenomenon so how the way that the
governments or NGOs who work on this
problem know the way they try to address
it is by doing either free or subsidized
food distribution or food for work
programs trying to create some
employment in that area now those
mechanisms are quite expensive for poor
countries right and also there's some
structural reasons like jobs don't exist
in that area so my idea was instead of
trying to force job creation where there
the economy doesn't support it why not
move people to where the jobs are the
perhaps moving people is going to be
cheaper than moving jobs so so I
followed up on that by conducting a
randomized control trial where you know
I use treatment groups versus control
groups to offer certain kind of program
to people and then track what happened
and in this case I encourage people to
move so in some villages I offered them
the equivalent of about eleven twelve
dollars which paid for a round-trip bus
fare plus a few days of food in other
villages I offered them information on
where they could go right and then I had
a control group where I collected data
but did not have the same thing and then
I tracked what what when what happened
next okay so it turns out the three
bottom-line results are first if you
provide people with some money either
the farm grant or a loan or the travel
cost you can induce people to go so
about a quarter of households try this
out they send a seasonal migrant right
for the period that that's the lean
season at home and when they go their
families consumed six to seven hundred
calories per person per day more and so
they move from two meals a day to three
meals a day which is a remarkably large
effect and the third thing that happened
is a year later and three years later I
continued tracking people in these areas
but I did not repeat the program and a
lot of the people who were induced to
move back in 2008 chose to go back again
in 2009 and 2011 and and then why were
they doing it it turns out that most of
the people who we induced
they go back and work for the exact same
employer that they hadn't met back in
2008
okay so what led you to do this kind of
research so I grew up in Bangladesh
so this is the problem that I grew up
with I mean not in my family I was in a
city hustle but it's a problem that most
most of us knew about and the government
was paying attention to so this is
something had been curious about and as
an economist the curiosity comes from
the fact that this is a entirely
predictable shock so how is it that when
a shock happens year after year
that people are not adjusting and and
still suffering the consequences of the
spamming okay so what were some of the
reasons why prior to your research that
someone wouldn't move excellent ask
that's exactly where the research went
next right so we did the research that I
just described and we found those
results and then the social scientists
in Maine would ask the question why did
we have to run this program you know if
this was so such a good idea in terms of
we could get people to go they eat more
they go back again on their own so they
should have been going already
the program should not have been
necessary right so then we go back to
economic theory
so we then try to understand okay why
was this phenomenon existing why were
people not moving okay so here's the
simple story that comes out of the
theory I won't use math here thank you
sir and so imagine I were to offer you a
lottery ticket it cost about eleven
dollars and and I tell you that about
80% of the time it'll pay off and you'll
get a lot of money back you'll get forty
fifty dollars back okay but 20% of the
time it won't pay off would you want to
buy that ticket of course because it's a
great deal however now imagine I told
you it's the same ticket except imagine
that you're under the threat of famine
and your family's very close to
subsistence right and there's a risk
that if you are 11 dollars poorer that
you buy a ticket and it doesn't pay off
right and you return home empty-handed
right that's something devastating like
am I would you buy that ticket under
those circumstances No so that's what's
going on so even though the upside
opportunity is great people cannot chase
those opportunities just because they're
not managing the downside risk so the
way that the program ended up working is
that it was actually working as
insurance not as a grant so we were
insuring people's travel and that made
them feel comfortable help them get over
their risk aversion and chase the upside
opportunity and
about 80% of the time it did work out so
those numbers I gave are actually from
the data in the study so I'm curious how
many villages did you look at for the
research so we worked in we started at a
hundred villages and we increased over
the course of three years to about one
hundred and thirty three and the
original sample was working with about
two thousand households and that
increased about three thousand by the by
the end of the three years okay and how
how did the people in the cities and
towns know about the research how did
you get the word out or how did you get
people to participate so we work with
local NGOs who actually provide lots of
services in those areas and they have
great local presence so this is all done
in collaboration with local institutions
who are interacting with villages on a
regular basis they providing microcredit
I see okay and now I'm also curious how
do they find the jobs to go to and what
kind of jobs were there yeah so it turns
out that a lot of people already
migrated even without us being there so
about 35 percent of the households were
migrating so the fact that I was talking
about is really moving that from 35
percent to about 60 percent so the
people who already were going but first
35 percent they usually have
pre-existing connections to employers
because they've traveled in the past or
they might have some social network
support family support in the
destination and it's interesting that
the people we were able to induce to
move that's 16 minus or 35 right they
were the people who did not have those
services available so that was actually
part of the risk which is I don't really
have a connection I don't really have
any support right it's too risky for me
to go and so for those people this
program acted as a substitute form of
insurance okay
so ultimately what do you conclude in
your paper so the important bottom line
here is that we now have an
understanding of why people weren't
going and that this actually is kind of
like a poverty trap which is that there
are nice opportunities available for you
however you're so poor that you cannot
take the risk to pursue those
opportunities right and that itself is
what's keeping people poor like
so so what this program does it's
helping people break out of that cycle
okay by insuring their risk okay through
micro-financing to a certain extent
exactly so except that you know
traditionally you think about
microfinance as the story that's solely
though people want to start businesses
we give the microfinance they're
entrepreneurs at heart and you know as
soon as you give them some capital they
start a business and they sell the
product right it turns out that story is
a myth
so most people in the world are not
entrepreneurs right just like you and me
they want steady jobs right so this is
this is a case where you know you can
use the microfinance
type concept right but allow people to
do what the majority of people actually
want to do okay and what do you think
this can help moving forward so I'm
going to help moving forward
sure so this was originally a you know I
randomized control trial research study
with only as I said 2000 to 3000 hustle
okay
now the reaction to this was people who
read the work including some very nice
rich people from Silicon Valley as well
as an organization that scales up
programs called evidence action so they
approached me saying oh we should be
thinking about our scaling up this
program because it seems to be effective
their own policy right so I was
enthusiastic that somebody's paying
attention however I was also a little
bit apprehensive that look I you know I
my reaction then was like I showed you
these results with two or three thousand
households and it works well for those
families however if you start in using
twenty thousand people thirty thousand
people or two hundred thousand people it
may not work in the same way so for
example if you move lots of people out
maybe you know if all the able-bodied
men leave some social scientists in the
path of expressed concerns that perhaps
that makes the origin bill is much more
vulnerable okay
or you might worried that if you send
lots of people into the city they might
stress the city's intake capacity right
or if there aren't enough jobs available
exactly yeah so it could be intake in
terms of jobs it could be in terms of
the Sanitation situation or housing
situation
and the another set of worries that I
that I expressed to them has to do with
unintended consequences so I told you a
number of results here about the
economic effects but it could be that
you know when people move to the city
they come back with new ideas that
political beliefs might change or they
might come back with a health problem
right and it might lead to more
transport of health issues from rural
and back to or from urban back to rural
area or it might change husband the
relationship between the husband and the
wife husband away I could lead to
divorce and it could have effects on
kids if the migrant are typically a male
is away from the family for a while so
so then the next step was to say look
these are the concerns and they're real
concerns if you think about scale up so
we should be thinking about each of
these problems and studying them
carefully before we launch a big program
to scale this scale there's the idea up
and so that's exactly what we did and so
I'll give you a quick flavor of how this
how this works so imagine you know to in
order to understand the effect on the
rural area so we move from a sample of
3,000 to an area with 30,000 people okay
so we scaled up by 10 times and in order
to study the effect on the rural area
what I did was in some villages I induce
lots of people to move in fact up to 70
percent of people and in some villages I
induce only a few people so it turns out
to be about 35 38 percent okay now with
that variation you can now see if lots
of people move out what happens to the
rest of the people remaining in the
village and that else next answer those
questions about what the spillover
effects are in the village and what you
find is actually even more good news
right really and the good news is when
lots of people move out then there's
less competition for the scarce jobs at
home right so you see that wages rise
because now employers need to pay more
in order to get workers and the people
remaining at home they they have an
easier time finding employment so
they're not as hungry there their income
goes up okay but what happens when
everyone comes back I'm typically how
long I we didn't talk about how long
you're away for right so it's typically
that period the pre-harvest main season
period is about a three month period and
typically people go for a few weeks and
in
they come back after say three or four
weeks because they want to bring money
back home and they want to see the
family and then they go again a second
time so I actually in that migrant
sample I about one point nine two trips
for a family during that period and so
when they come back so then we tracked
you know effects on husband wife's
relationships really attractive like
these kind of sociological effects help
issues we track political changes
political beliefs changes right and also
how the decision-making within the
household might change right it turns
out in general there are not nothing
interesting going on it's all a set of
zero effects
Wow and the reason is so I'll tell you
the simple story that okay the weeks
that the husband is away of course by
definition the wife makes more decisions
right however as soon as it comes back
it goes back to status quo so it's not
like this is a program that will
increase women's empowerment like well
that is interesting though because I'm
wondering if that will hold over time
yeah so I think it's because you know
women's empowerment or husband wife
position within a family these are
things that are determined over
centuries right and I suspect an
intervention that makes somebody move up
for a few weeks it's not any powerful
enough if I do this so so that that was
another meant that came out of the
microfinance literature they claim that
that's what we're happening but I just
think I think it's a like in the large
sample data does not really bear it out
okay and are you looking to apply this
model to other countries I know you're
working in several other countries yes
so now that we feel a lot more
comfortable so in Bangladesh where I'll
call it a scale-up phase right so in the
next four years we will be making offers
to about a half a million household
trying to induce about 300,000 people to
move so that's the level of funding that
we have there and this is being
conducted by evidence action in
partnership with one of the NGOs that we
originally work with in the in the study
who had very good local presence okay
you mean I'm Bangladesh just bones what
are you doing it in other countries and
also in other countries are going to
yeah we're looking at replication and
the second place we're going to is in
eastern Indonesia so Indonesia is a
richer country than manga - but the
eastern island
like just not of Australia those are
very poor places where the same
phenomenon of seasonal hunger exists so
we've been working there for the last
few years in partnership with the
government there the planning ministry
and we are now launching the project in
the Indonesian part of Timor like a
province called entity and then just two
weeks ago I was in Sulawesi at another
island Indonesia with a group of Yale
students and we were exploring the
possibilities there okay interesting so
we'll look forward to seeing what goes
on there - final question you know in
reading the Financial Times you know I
originally saw the coverage of your work
there and it describes it as an example
for house for how intelligent
international development and full
philanthropy sille Anthropy should be
done so my question to you are what are
the lessons that we can draw from this
for other research and philanthropic
projects so I think one important lesson
is that we shouldn't take a result even
if it looks very promising and
immediately start applying it elsewhere
right each place is different sure and
the one-size-fits-all policy might not
work so for example when I went to
Indonesia I learned that in Timor even
though people are hungry before the
harvest over there people actually have
land unlike in Bangladesh where most
people are landless right but the land
quality is low so because they have land
they need to stay back home between
planting and harvest to do the little
bit of tasks like weeding so they don't
want to migrate then even though that's
when they're hungry right and so what we
learn is that they're actually willing
to mark migrate after the harvest when
they're free they're more free time
thinking ahead to the fact that they
will be hungry in the next we have is
even right so the program design changed
okay and then we also explored a
replication in Malawi and Zambia so I
actually sent you know we did some
exploration sent a Yale student there to
spend the summer right and there we
learned that in Malawi it turns out that
there is no city with a vibrant labor
market that can absorb migrants sure
right and so we just stopped our
activities there right away so I think
you know thinking about the local
conditions right and then also thinking
carefully about okay if I do a study
with 3000 households how will the
results be
matically different if we do the program
with 30,000 or 300,000 also that's
really important and those are the types
of questions that the government should
be asking right we do research because
we want to inform large-scale policy not
to just start with the research right
but now I think we need to start
developing the science behind scaling up
interventions right so if you take a
small-scale research result is there can
we immediately apply it to large scale
or what are the set of systemic problems
that we will face and how do we address
those questions right because so much
money I think especially previously
mining is thrown at at a problem and you
know there's no real understanding of
what was going on or any follow up so I
think what you're doing is very
important
thank you yes and so the data are
important but this last thing that I
said about systemically thinking about
the science suggests that we also need
to go back to economic theory right and
talk to not just people who analyze data
that people who think about the theory
of change exactly so thank you so much
for being here with us today and sharing
your work thank you very much for more
information about professor mubarak and
his work please visit our website at
macmillan report yale.edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Eddie
Macmillan Centre for International and
area studies at you
[Music]